going to technology is something that's
inevitable people will go to technology
because technology is spreading far and
wide it does offer some advantages but
to think that technology alone will
solve problems is not quite right I
think there are a few fundamental issues
here let's assume that you can get a
hundred percent connectivity to Internet
and all that let's say all that is true
the biggest problem in using technology
is that if you use technology to improve
the learning outcomes under the present
curriculum in the present education
system then there's a conflict the
technology information technology is
essentially a non-linear tool you can go
to the internet and surf just about any
content whereas the education system as
it has existed over the 200 years is a
very linear one somebody out there in
Washington or London or Delhi decides
what you're going to learn in fifth
grade and sixth grade and seventh grade
and that's the boring part whereas the
kids are learning the nonlinear stuff
our life is become has become nonlinear
it's not assembly line anymore we don't
stand in lines anymore you want a book a
cinema ticket you want a book of
Broadway ticket you want a book an
airline ticket you just go on it and do
stuff and this is true of production
everything has become nonlinear except
where seasons are concerned whereas the
learning systems have remained linear
now when you take technology and place
it in the learning environment if you
make it subservient to the current
linear system then the power of the
technology is constrained and then to
that extent it is not effective then its
effect is only as much as the school
system's effect whereas if you were to
remove it from the education school
education system and say the school
system the learning system should be now
changed to suit the new technology then
you have a particular advantage the
question is how you do it second part is
in our parts of the world at least I
can't say much about the developed world
due to our shall we say feudal culture
where you have to listen to the elders
with of course it's changing a little
bit sometimes it's good to listen to
elders but you have to you go to the
teacher the teacher is the one who gives
you answers and the pretension is that
the teacher knows the answers or the
textbook nor the answers or somebody
knows the answers whereas the whole idea
is that in the modern world you should
be looking for answers you should become
a self learner because there's so much
out there to be learned and there's no
way that the content that humanity is
generated over so many hundred years can
be absorbed over five ten fifteen
sixteen years so the important thing is
to learn the skills of learning to learn
cooperatively the old system says you
are gonna learn and you're going to
appear for the exam the new system is
saying you can work in groups and learn
and crack the problem so I think we need
to fundamentally change the way we are
learning the way that we are being
assessed and certified as well so
policymakers very clearly everybody says
put computers in the kids hands that's
only part of the problem in in my part
of the world even the content is not
available in local languages if I go to
youtube I can watch many things but I
can't translate that because they're
copyright issues so after all those
things are done I think we'll be ready
for a proper serious use of technology
right now the technology is only a
helper in the current inefficient system